mix up centuries politics and Maps throw
in a little narrative confusion and
finish it off with some over-the-top CGI
Madness King Arthur just can't catch a
break on screen but could there be hope
many adaptations Place King Arthur in a
vague medieval fantasy-ish England
perhaps because it's easier than
explaining the historical political and
cultural realities of their version of
the character
welcome to Camelot but this Reliance on
obscurity creates its own mess of
problems Arthur's Origins are British
not English by British we mean the
various protonic-speaking Celts of
sub-roman Britain that would come to be
known as kimri these are primarily the
modern day Welsh Cornish and Breton and
by English we mean the various Germanic
tribes primarily the Saxons juts and
angles that would come to be known as
English many scholars believe that if
Arthur was a single individual who
actually existed he would have been part
of sub-roman Britain's Fifth and 6th
Century resistance to Saxon Invasion
here's the thing the Irish or Scots at
the time in the pits of modern day
Scotland were also taking advantage of
the fractured weakened state in which
Rome's withdrawal had left Arthur's
Britain surrounded by threats on all
sides the odds were insurmountable and
yet historical evidence suggests that
for at least a couple Generations
someone possibly even a guy named Arthur
was able to unite his countrymen fend
off these enemies and bring peace and
stability to the region
none of this means that Arthur hasn't
been extremely important to English
Identity or that he can't be depicted as
English it simply means that
screenwriters have to decide who or what
their Arthur will be fighting
the issue isn't that so many adaptations
get the tradition or history wrong but
that so few of them see this decision as
integral to their story without
insurmountable odds and a lost cause
Arthur's story has no meaning
John borman's Excalibur doesn't trouble
itself with such decisions instead
Borman stuffs his movie with as many
King Arthur allegories as he can but no
tangible enemy for most of the film well
hi devil then in My Kingdom
that leaves us with one of the least
compelling authors in recent history
understandably tricky to make Arthur's
Big Bad the Saxons in a narrative that
positions him as an English hero but the
protagonists and villains of guy
Richie's King Arthur legend of the sword
are so vague that it's difficult to care
about either faction sure the linguistic
mishmash and Ladish flash forwards feel
arbitrary and out of place in the CGI
Reliant tornado of fantasy vomit but
they're not even the worst aspect of
legend of the sword sadly they might be
the best part Tell me story about a girl
called Lucy a viking cold Gray beard or
some Rebel graffiti dirty in these walls
are you writing a book the film isn't
set in any particular real-life era or
place that could work except that the
world we are given is so scattered and
generic in its otherworldliness that we
can't place relate to or derive any
meaning from it
Legends like Arthur endured not because
of their fantasy but because of our
Collective belief in and need for their
reality we want to believe in Arthur as
if he's a real person and while that
doesn't mean he needs to be realistic it
does mean we need to see our real world
hopes and struggles reflected in his
story Richie's World provides no such
reflection there's a universe in which
Richie's film comments on the abuse of
power that the wealthy wield over the
working class but that universe is not
this one which brings us to writer David
franzoni and director Antoine fuqua's
pile of anachronistic chaos 2004's King
Arthur fuke was mistake isn't that he
keeps things too vague it's that he
tries to be specific and accurate but in
the most confusing manner possible we
can forgive the film for calling the
pics woes and for dressing said woes and
leather nipple belts we can even forgive
it for weaving 12th century story
editions into its 5th Century narrative
since frankly no one wants to see an
Arthur without a Merlin and a Lancelot
the rest of this however is historically
unforgivable the film opens with the
words historians agree that and there's
our first issue historians don't agree
on anything least of all Arthur and this
inaccurate and inadequate appeal to
Authority is a sign of things to come
not only does franzoni have a Roman
Elite living several days north of
Hadrian's Wall he also has sacks and
tribes invading Britain from the
northwest corner of modern-day Scotland
did these 5th Century Saxons come from
Iceland was their map upside down we
can't know there are other historical
and geographical issues here but they
pale in comparison to the film's
confused understanding of subroman
Britain in the 2004 film Clive Owens
Arthur gallops around shouting about
personal freedom while attempting to
free his Warriors of their service and
poor Farmers from the lands they serve
these are our orders we leave at first
light and when we return your freedom
we'll be waiting for you what this
Arthur is effectively doing is ensuring
these people have no food no community
no protection in times of war and
nowhere to live
there are so many issues with this film
including its half-baked use of sea
Scott Littleton and ANSI Thomas's
summation connection its complete
misrepresentation of pelagianism and its
wacky portrayal of both the Romano
British and the pits again there's a
universe in which Arthur as a champion
of inherent individual Freedom makes
sense but that universe is 18th century
France not 5th Century Rome or Britain
that said the fact that King Arthur at
least attempts to give its leader a
cause places it firmly above stars as
failed medieval series Camelot in this
accidental parody of itself Ava Green's
Morgan exists solely to glare seduce and
serve as a warning about the dangers of
female ambition we're given no reason to
care about the series's tweenish Arthur
save the fact that he is Arthur or for
the one-dimensional Guinevere it's
possible Camelot had Redemption arcs in
mind but you can't build on a busted
Foundation
Camelot like the vast majority of all
on-screen Arthurian adaptations is a bit
like watching a first grader recite
Shakespeare the words are there but the
comprehension and delivery are not
ironically they usually are there in
Productions aimed at younger audiences
adaptations such as Disney's The Sword
and the stone for instance benefit from
being forced to think about what the
message is in the process of relaying it
more simply Arthurian parodies benefit
from this deconstruction process as well
ooh the bittens well we all are we are
all britons and I am your king
is now he had a king I thought we're an
autonomous Collective the more serious
adaptations have managed to strike the
right balance of subtext context history
and plot it's almost always because
they've chosen to focus on a single
character or storyline from The Wider
tradition
this is why Jerry zucker's first night
isn't one of the worst Arthurian movies
ever made at the very least first night
focuses on a single element of the
legend and is fairly clear about what
its Arthur is attempting to create it
also provides a nuanced and relatively
historically informed understanding of
pretend etwa's famous courtly love
triangle does this mean adaptations
can't succeed if they attempt to tell
the whole story no at least not if they
use their Source material wisely you'd
be hard-pressed to find a version of the
Arthurian Legend that's truer to its
historical and cultural Origins than
Bernard Cornwell's warlord Chronicles
the trilogy is so fully embedded in what
little history we know of the time
period And so thoroughly informed by
breathonic mythology that it's easy to
forget that these are works of fiction
written in the 90s the first-hand
account we're given is Through The Eyes
of an aging pseudo monk named durphil
who was once Arthur's loyal friend every
time durfle reveals a gap between the
Legend and his lived experiences we get
the impression that for the first time
we actually are hearing the real story
Cornwell's Trilogy finds a way to
historically reposition and ground the
well-known elements of Arthurian Legend
it's an effective and easily adaptable
structure and since Cornwall has already
done the research required to resolve
the historical Arthur with the literary
one bad Wolf's upcoming television
adaptation won't have to wrestle with
that aspect unless it decides not to
trust its audience it also won't have to
decide what its Arthur represents
Cornwell's Arthur stories are political
in nature meaning that they speak to the
political mechanics of a just Society
what I do now I do for my people
and for Camelot
in the trilogy's first novel The Winter
King Cornwall tells us exactly how his
Arthur thinks Society should operate
Arthur believes a king is only as good
as the poorest man under his Rule and
that the strong or Duty bound to protect
the weak he believes Justice can't exist
unless Oaths are kept and the laws of a
land apply to every citizen battles
should be fought only to secure peace
and he never creates a round table of
perfect nights only a Brotherhood of
Britain that relies on various leaders
putting old grudges to rest in the name
of keeping that piece he's not a king
but a warrior sworn to secure the
kingdom of demnonia or modern-day Devon
and Cornwall until the infant King
Mordred comes of age Arthur's goal is to
unite the warring tribes and kingdoms of
Britain so they can defend themselves
against the Saxons the Irish and the
raiding Northern tribes it's not
particularly romantic to think of Arthur
as a politician but in the broadest
sense of the term that's precisely what
he has to become in order to secure and
maintain the peace like most politicians
Arthur's personal Ambitions are in
constant conflict with his political
ideals which are themselves in constant
conflict with reality
Cornwell's entire narrative is a story
of lenses and of tensions both within
the individual and society as a whole
nowhere are these tensions more apparent
than an Arthur's embodiment of them for
all his lofty ideology Cornwell's Arthur
himself breaks Oaths fights battles in
the names of things other than peace and
can't help but enjoy the thrill of
battle he may be an idealist but he
lives as we do in an unideal world that
world is ugly brutal and continually
tests his strength not with CGI monsters
or a crisis of Christian faith but with
a crisis of faith in himself and by
extension Humanity like every society
that's ever lived Arthur's triumphs and
defeats are cyclical but to believe in
Arthur is to believe that a better
version of humanity is possible despite
this cycle even when the odds are
insurmountable
we don't keep resurrecting The Once and
Future King because he represents a
pretty version of the once but because
he inspires us to fight for the future
fantasy Arthur can't do that in 2023 but
Cornwell's Arthur can in the second
novel durphil argues how powerful ideals
in an unideal world can be to hear the
tales told at nighttime hearths you
would think we had made a whole new
country in Britain named it Camelot and
peopled it with shining Heroes but the
truth is that we simply ruled demonia as
best we could we ruled it justly and we
never called it Camelot Camelot exists
only in the poet's dreams while in our
demonia even in those good years the
Harvest still failed the plagues still
ravaged us and wars were still fought
it's easy to believe in Camelot it's
infinitely harder and infinitely more
heroic to believe in and fight for the
world in which we actually live
now we just have to hope this adaptation
sees the romance in an Arthur Who
through his holy unromantic Humanity can
actually speak to that world
[Music]
foreign